جاء هؤلاء للظفر بقطعه خبز ليست كسواها
فهذا المخبز يملكه الفائز بمسابقه احسن
خبزه بباريس لهذا العام
تزامنا مع عباره الثناء والتهنئه التي
يتلقاها من زبائنه لا يخفي الخباز فرشان
سلفرجه الذي ينحدر من اصول سريلانكيه فخره
بعمله الذي يؤديه بحب وشغف رغم حداثه عهده
بهذه الحرفه النسبيا
كل الفرنسيين ياكلون الخبز صباحا ومساء
وبعد الظهر وبالتالي العمل كخباز هو امر
جيد اضافه الى انه عمل تقليدي والخبز
ياكله الجميع من فقراء واغنياء وانا احب
عملي لهذا اخترته
بعد فوزه باللقب من المرشح ان يزود فرشان
قصراليزي الخبز لمده سنه يوميا كما جرت
العاده لكن اقبال الفرنسيين الكبيره على
الخبز لم يعد بنفس قدر اقبالهم على هذه
الحرفه
تشهد فرنسا عزوفا نسبيا في اقبال الشباب
على مهنه الخباز يعز اهل الاختصاص ذلك الى
صعوبه العمل وكثره متطلباته اضافه الى
الرواتب التي يرى البعض انها لا تتماشى مع
الجهود المبذوله
اكثر من 95% من الفرنسيين يستهلكون الخبز
كل يوم ونحو 30 مليون خبزه تباع يوميا في
فرنسا هنا قرب كنيس نوتردام في قلب باريس
يحتفل الفرنسيون
فيتبع الناس على اسرار اعداد الخبز
التقليدي بمراحله المختلفه ويفاخر
الخبازون بان عملهم يمثل فنا فرنسيا قائما
بذاته
فخورون بتقديم عملنا ومهاراتنا وهو امر
اعترفت به اليونسكو بتصنيفنا ضمن التراث
العالمي خلال شهر نوفمبر الماضي مهاراتنا
تتمثل في صنع خبز جيد لكن ذلك يعود ايضا
للفلاحين الذين يوزعون لنا انواعا جيده
ومختلفه من القمح
يتسابق الخبازون للفوز بلقب احسن خبزه
باغيت في فرنسا فيخدع الخبز الى عمليه
تقييم شامله ودقيقه للخبز مكانه
كثيره خفيه وجزءا اصيلا من هويتها ممكنه
من دخول قائمه التراث العالمي ليونسكو
حافظ مربح الجزيره باريس